et pour en parler nous sommes en direct
avec alix rivière vice président de la
fcpe 93 la fédération des conseils de
parents d'élèves de seine-saint-denis
bonjour alix rivière merci d'être en
direct avec nous sur rt france alors on
vient de voir les recommandations de
l'académie de médecine pour la
réouverture des écoles prévue à partir
du 11 mai qu'en pensez vous nous parents
nous sommes consternés l'environné
complètement est il du processus de
réflexion en amont de la reprise de
l'école
enfin à se dire on découvre en même
temps que tout le monde merci aux médias
aux français qu'ils venaient la parole
sur le ronde parce qu'on découvre à
travers effectivement la communication
sur la pensée scientifique de l'académie
de médecine du ministère de l'éducation
nationale où effectivement de matignon
ou l'elysée ce qu'ils ont décidé pour
nos enfants nous on passe nos semaines
depuis le début du confinement à
répondre aux parents et à désamorcer en
permanence toutes les angoisses
légitimes des parents nounous consterné
que effectivement les parents soient ce
soit ne soit pas associé dé lui ce qui
est écrit dire qu'en gros mes parents
ils sont considérés comme des moutons
qui s'attroupent devant les écoles et on
nous demande de demander à nos enfants
de se laver les mains mais est-ce qu'on
a attendu les recommandations du conseil
scientifique ou l'académie de médecine
ou du gouvernement augmente à nos
enfants de se laver les mains
nous on sait que dans les établissements
ça fait des décennies que ça dure moi je
vais être cinquantenaire déjà à mon
époque c'était compliqué les toilettes
aujourd'hui rien n'a changé il n'y a pas
de réflexion globale sur l'hygiène
collectif et nous par représentants de
parents école par école collège par
école lycée par lycée on serait en
mesure de dire aux parents terrain c'est
à dire aux parents de nos villes dégradé
que nous connaissons voilà cela se passe
et voilà comment esprit effectivement
nombre d'associés et voilà ce que nous
on nous demande de faire et voilà le
constat qu'on peut faire et au lieu de
ça et les préconisations qui sont
verticales qui descendent ne
fonctionneront pas d'autant qu'en plus
une fois de plus jean michel blanquer a
encore un problème de ressources
humaines avec ses professeurs
et l'autre chose qui est inadmissible
c'est de ne pas associer les agents
d'entretien les élèves en processus non
on est furax oggi comme je le pense
parce que nous on passe des heures au
téléphone avec les parents
l'établissement indiqué nous sommes élus
- à titre personnel et je pense que je
suis pas la seule
on est à peu près je recharge propres et
mon téléphone portable trois fois par
jour enfin si on est dans un monde
surréaliste alors une circulation
une situation qui tranche un peu avec la
situation italienne puisque le
gouvernement préfère lui une rentrée en
septembre
c'est ce qu'a décidé de zapper quand est
ce matin 1 pour ne pas mettre en jeu la
santé des enfants le conseil
scientifique aussi aurait préféré une
réouverture des écoles en septembre
c'est ce que les parents d'élèves
souhaitent également l'initiation
totalement irrationnel est ce que vous
pensez sincèrement que l'on a vis russie
l'asie ronald à c'est moi septembre qui
arrivent là il faut faire quelque chose
pour je m'arrête
mais non mais c'est enfin je veux dire
même sage des prises de positions qui
sont irrationnels je dire aujourd'hui la
seule certitude que l'on a c'est que le
respect des gestes barrières permet
effectivement de d'être d'être efficace
donc
donc est-ce qu'on travaille sur la mise
en place réelle les gestes barrière dans
les écoles en prenant en prenant pour
exemple par exemple qui se passe en ce
moment au danemark
qu'est ce qui se passe en suède le japon
vient de re confiné je vous rappelle
qu'on le conseil scientifique japonais
n'a pas osé prendre position parce que
c'est notre culture et que se rétracter
chez eux c'est qu'on est très compliqué
les danois ils sont par un petit groupe
de quatre enfants dans les classes avec
avec les joues pari du nouveau collectif
pour le récit de classe par classe
donc est ce qu est ce qu on peut faire
un petit peu preuve d'unité écouter les
uns et les autres et en particulier les
personnels qui s'occupe réellement
d'hygiène collectif dans les
établissements et qui sont pour la
plupart souvent méprisé mais justement
est-ce que ça c'est réalisable qu'elle
voit la recommandation faudrait-il
prendre caisse comment vous discuter
entre vous comment vous vous voyez les
choses mais nous voudraient un constat
école par école collège par collège
lycée par lycée pour avoir une vision
totalement réaliste de la situation à ce
que le parce que giraud début du
confinement on a découvert au début de
cette pandémie on a découvert qu
effectivement les enfants nous parents
le premier geste de coéducation confirme
viser une école c'est leur apprendre
justement ils viennent à se laver les
mains à respecter les lieux etc
comment est ce qu'on fait pour inclure
dans les projets éducatifs de chaque
établissement scolaire le respect la
continuité de ses gestes
je veux dire c'est un travail de fourmi
et qui ne passe pas par les annonces
gouvernementales et des joutes
politiques dont les enfants n'ont rien
faire et ce sont les enfants aujourd'hui
qu'ils vont faire les frais de sa et
derrière ça les conséquences parce que
vous mettez dans la tête des enfants que
de ne pas respecter les gestes barrières
et de ne pas participer les jeunes
collectif c'est aussi potentiellement
les transformer en contaminateur et
atteindre leurs proches
moi j'aimerais bien qu'on arrête de
rendre nos enfants fut alors dernière
question c'est toutefois que le retour à
l'école le 11 mai n'est pas obligatoire
chaque parent pourra décider voilà que
son enfant aille à l'école ou pas à
quelle proportion d'élèves ou vous
attendez vous pour cette rentrée en tout
cas concernant voilà votre entourage et
les parents d'élèves avec qui vous êtes
en contact mais c'est très variable
quand vous avez un enfant qui nous
déprimer quand vous avez un parent qui
est déprimé je veux dire c'est autant de
décisions que deux parents et sa relaxe
est décision revient aux seuls parents
moi en ce qui me concerne mais devient
les enfants sont en lice et donc ils ont
eu leur professeur au téléphone vendredi
qu'ils auront dix bombes à l'école
reprend le 18 mai pour eux donc n'est
pas de sujet enfin ils sont en bonne
santé ils n'attendent qu'une chose c'est
une resocialisation au sein de leur
lycée
mais à côté de ça j'ai des amis qui
effectivement ont des enfants qui sont
une des prix mais avec des maladies
orphelines ou un papa ou une maman qui a
un cancer dont quand vous êtes sous
chimiothérapie vous êtes deux fait
déprimer
il ya autant de cac et autant de
décisions que carl pratiquement défini
si la proportion à lui franchement
c'était compliqué la seule chose c'est
que nous on dit décrypteur de du système
éducatif
ils nous appellent et nous on aimerait
bien pouvoir leur passer un message
éclairé et en l'occurrence le message
vertical tout leur sens n'est pas clair
merci beaucoup
alix rivière d'avoir pris le temps de
répondre à nos questions je rappelle que
vous êtes vice président de la fcpe de
seine saint denis la fédération des
conseils de parents d'élèves merci